Hello Dr. Kevin Conner's for your member minute for today. Today we're going to talk about cancer and
alkalinity. You read a lot about acid alkalinity and cancer that you might have read that cancer can't grow in an
alkaline body, so we need to alkalize our body. That's the problem. We're acidic. That's why we get cancer.
Well, I beg to differ with that just a little bit. No, that might be the truth, but the problem with cancer
three things remember.
One apoptosis is not taking place. Apoptosis is normal program cell depth. That's what's to take place.
What is cell replicates? The mother cell dies. That lives for a period of time replicates. We won't get into that now.
Second thing is replication.
So replication is accelerated. So if I have a
cell line that isn't going through apoptosis and it's in rapid replication that is cancer.
The third thing is that the immune system has to be diminished because in order for somebody to get cancer, they have to not have an
immune response against that cancer. So this happens in all of us. It's happening in me right now. If I have a healthy immune system,
this is cleaning it up and keeping it at bay. The immune system kills things. Get it kills, throw in cancer cells.
However, when I talk about that today, but you need to have an understanding of that to understand what I'm going to say next.
So cancer is this cell line that is replicating and replicating and replicating and replicating and replicating and
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger.
Now, normally your cells replicate every few days to every six, 12 weeks to a year, so they don't replicate very fast.
So let's say use my liver as an example again. It replicates typically about every six weeks. If it's in a
cancerous state, state, cell is in rapid replication, so cancer is growing. It might be replicating six times a day.
The act of replication gives off a lot of waste. So normally, so normally in my body,
my liver cell
is replicating another cell and then this cell dies.
Well, the metabolism that goes on inside this cell gives off waste.
That waste goes into the space between the cells. There's all sorts of cells here.
That waste between the cells is called the extracellular space, or the extracellular matrix, because it's not really a space that's occupied by fluid and waste.
This waste is acidic. Well, that's not usually a problem because you have these things called open-ended capillaries here that drain back to the veins and drain out of the body.
It's called your live system. So your live system is kind of like a storm sewer. So the storm sewer picks up all this waste.
It flows out here because you exercise today and move the fluids through your body and all this waste goes through here and it gets out of your body.
That's great. So that's what happens normally. But in a cancer patient, this is replicating really fast.
So we have this cancer cells that are replicating, replicating, replicating, replicating, replicating.
It is building up this acidic slime layer of waste around this growing mass.
The live vatic system can never keep up with it. It can't keep up with it.
So we've got this acidic slime layer that is the waste of the cancer cells that also act as the protective barrier.
So then I have my immune system. So let's say now I get healthy and I'm eating right and I'm trying to do the right things and my stress is going.
So I have a macrophage that's trying to go and destroy that. Well, it can't penetrate this slime-waste layer and it can't even get in there to kill it.
So does cancer grow into the acidic environment or an alkaline environment? Well, cancer really creates an acidic environment.
So is it still good to alkalize myself then? Absolutely. You want to alkalize yourself. You have to alkalize your tissue. That's one of the benefits of the rife.
The rife is using a light wave. A light carries a photon on the wave. That's what a true rife does.
It's a light wave that's hitting you at the frequency of the cancer. So it's attacking the cancer with a light wave.
The photon acts as an electron donor when it's an electron donor due to the tissue. It raises the pH. You're alkalizing the cancer. That's one of the reasons why the rife works.
You're alkalizing this. You're breaking this down. So this live vatic, this white blood cell response could get in there and start killing the cancer.
That's what we're trying to do. So this acidic slime layer has to be broken down. That's why you use things like enzymes in medicinal mushrooms and all the things that I write about in my book to try to get in there to break that down to get in there and kill the cancer.
That's what the rife does also. So cancer only does not grow in an alkaline environment. Well, that's not really true. Cancer creates an acidic environment.
So it is true you want to alkalize yourself. That's why you juice and you use enzymes in vegetables and all this kind of good food that you're trying to eat.
But it is, don't mix up those, that terminology.